okay let's talk today about Iran
Venezuela and Syria and I mentioned
yesterday that I want to discuss the
Putin angle on the latest Iran stuff but
I also want to talk about it in the
larger context and there's a really good
post about this on our subreddit david
pakman.com slash reddit which outlines
sort of the underlying idea that i want
to present to you here and it's
something i've been thinking about i
thought about it over the weekend as the
iran news was breaking and i've
continued thinking about it and the idea
is that in the end donald trump may be
destined to stay out of iran and stay
out of venezuela and ultimately stay out
of syria in any serious way because
staying out of those three countries
shares a common thread which is that
it's in vladimir putin's and russia's
interests for the united states to stay
out of those three countries now III
know I know that I have to issue this
disclaimer I hope we can be mature here
okay this is not Putin is literally
telling Trump what to do although who
knows what they've talked about in
private we actually don't know but it's
the trend once again that in the end
when the rubber meets the road
Trump ends up taking the path that is in
Russia's interests and this is not about
collusion or Trump criminality or
anything like that
it's about geopolitical realities it's
about the realities of the dynamics that
are forming as I've talked to you about
many times now among the three major
superpowers right now the United States
China and Russia in a way that is not
very good for the United States under
Donald Trump Iran Venezuela and Syria
are three allies of Russia and the trend
in Donald Trump's presidency it's not a
hundred percent but it's a high
percentage is that in the end rhetoric
aside Trump ends up acting in a way that
protects or doesn't go against or
threaten Russia's interests and let's go
through them one by one here Trump does
a big boy and he attacks Syria except he
attacked an empty runway at an airport
after telling Russia that he was going
to do it and it was back up and running
within a couple of days if not more like
hours and so for all of the tough talk
Trump does effectively nothing now this
doesn't mean I want Trump intervening in
Syria what we're doing here is an
analysis of how Trump's actions relate
to Russia's interests not me saying I
want Trump to take a B or C action
that's Syria Venezuela number two in the
winter as I told you last week Donald
Trump was looking very hard at going
into Venezuela forcing regime change to
be clear I don't want him to do that
I'm glad that Donald Trump didn't do
that don't email me saying I want Trump
to intervene in Venezuela because I
don't but last week I told you that
there are some new reports from inside
sources would say that Donald Trump
simply got bored and sort of lost
patience with the complexity of the
entire Venezuela thing which is totally
believable but once again in the end it
favors Vladimir Putin Putin and the
shabbos Maduro regime are tight we know
that much of the change in Donald
Trump's focus on Venezuela happened
after a phone call with Vladimir Putin
in early May and once again in the end
Donald Trump takes the path that at
least in the immediate is the one that
protects Russia's interests and favors
favors Vladimir Putin and then number
three we now have Iran yes the bluster
against Iran the threats the sanctions
and threats of sanctions backing out of
the Iran deal the entire thing we told
you about yesterday including Donald
Trump authorizing a strike against Iran
over the weekend but then calling it off
says it was over civilian casualty
estimates which may be true but once
again Trump despite the domineering
rhetoric ends up taking the action or
more accurately not taking the action
that favors Vladimir Putin and is in
Russia's interests so again please don't
make this out to be me saying anything
other than what I'm actually saying I am
NOT saying Trump is personally colluding
with Putin on these three foreign policy
situations
I'm not alleging to alleging or pointing
to some kind of conspiracy I'm pointing
out that in the end Donald Trump is
taking the paths here that Putin would
want him to take if you're concerned
with what's in the United States best
interests then you have to be concerned
about the u.s. increasingly being in a
position relative to the two to the two
other major superpowers Russia and China
who as I've told you before are
increasingly working together at the
disadvantage of and exclusion of the
United States now maybe you don't care
about that I mean there are people who
even though they might live in the
United States as most but not all of our
audience does who don't care if the
United States is better or worse
position than they say we're all humans
I don't care about country borders and I
don't care as long as we raise the
overall well-being that's my concern I
don't care what happens to the United
States many of us even on the Left who
live in the United States are invested
in the United States being a good place
to live in a place that has a good
standard of living and the relationships
we would like to see with other
countries and so we do care about this
so please don't start with the you know
I must be a war monger stuff because I'm
criticizing Trump for not going into
Iran Syria or Venezuela I want Bashar al
Assad out for the sake of the Syrian
people but not at the hands of the
United States I think the United States
needs to stay totally out of Venezuela I
do not want Donald Trump starting a war
with Iran this is not about me
personally these erratic maneuvers by
Trump are odd baiting Iran into action
pulling the u.s. out of the Iran deal
getting the opportunity to keep
escalating and then now last-minute
bailing on the escalation if a
Democratic president had done this it
would be every low-rent right-wing
analyst on Fox News 24/7 talking about
how weak Obama or Hillary or whoever was
by virtue of taking the action that
Donald Trump has taken so my concern is
the underlying geopolitical concerns
that exist here and number two whether
Donald Trump is actually in the end
making the decisions that even he
believes are in the best interests of
the United States I know that I wouldn't
agree with his conclusions about what's
best for the United States but at least
I would like to believe that in good
faith that's what his decisions are
informed by even if I would disagree
with the conclusions it's not clear that
that's going on based on how at least
these three situations are playing out
in the end let me know you're thinking
about this and play a few
gonna do the conspiratorial you know
allegations
don't even bother I'm not going to
respond I'm not going to engage but if
you have a serious thought about what
I've laid out here I actually do want to
hear from you